hagamos algunos cálculos usando la
actividad óptica en el primer problema
tenemos cero punto 300 gramos de
colesterol natural
esta es la estructura del colesterol
natural que es un compuesto ópticamente
activo y lo vamos a disolver en 15.0
mililitros de cloroformo esa solución la
pondremos en el tubo de un polar y metro
que mide 10 puntos 0 centímetros y la
rotación observada a 20 grados celsius
usando la línea de de sodio es de -0
punto 630 grados
nuestro objetivo es calcular la rotación
específica del colesterol bueno
en el vídeo anterior vimos que la
rotación específica es igual a la
rotación observada entre la
concentración por la longitud del tubo
vamos a sustituir los valores la
rotación específica es igual a la
rotación observada que es de -0 punto
630 grados
0 punto 630 grados entre la
concentración que debe estar en gramos
sobre mililitro entonces sería 0 punto
300 gramos entre 15.000 punto 300 gramos
/ 15.03
y esto lo multiplicamos por la longitud
del tubo que debe estar en decímetros
nosotros tenemos 10.00 y justamente esto
es igual a un 10 y metro esto nos
facilita mucho las cosas entonces por
1.000 decímetros usemos la calculadora
tenemos menos 0 punto 630 entre 0.3
cientos / 15.0 esto lo multiplicamos por
1 aunque no es necesario pero lo haré de
todos modos por 1.00 esto es igual a
menos 30 y 1.5 entonces nuestra rotación
específica a 20 grados celsius 20 usando
la línea de de sodio escribamos t es
igual a menos 30 y 1.5
ahora algunas veces puede que esto lo
encuentren en grados pero lo voy a
quitar porque en general la rotación
específica no tiene unidades todo
depende del libro que use en el problema
número 2 hablemos del porcentaje de
exceso en anti um erico o pureza óptica
que es igual al porcentaje que tenemos
de un enantiómero menos el porcentaje
del otro enantiómero en el inciso a hay
que calcular el porcentaje de exceso en
anti américo para una solución que sólo
contiene un enantiómero entonces como
sólo tenemos un enantiómero esto es muy
parecido al problema anterior porque
significa que tenemos el 100% de éste
enantiómero y obviamente 0% del otro así
que el porcentaje de exceso en anti
homérico es igual a 100 menos 0
y esto es igual al 100% tenemos el 100
por ciento de pureza óptica esta es una
solución óptica mente pura ahora vamos
con el inciso b hay que hacer el cálculo
para una solución que contiene
cantidades iguales de los 2 enantiómero
si a esto se le conoce como mezcla race
mica entonces como tenemos la misma
cantidad de los dos podemos decir que
tenemos 50% de un enantiómero y 50% del
otro así que el porcentaje de exceso en
anti américo es igual a 50 menos 50 y
claro esto es igual a 0 en este caso
tenemos una pureza óptica del 0% y de
hecho una mezcla race mica no es
ópticamente activa es decir no hay
rotación cuando tenemos la misma
cantidad de los dos en ante o menos
bueno finalmente en el inciso c tenemos
una solución que contiene
5 % de un enantiómero y 25% del otro así
que el porcentaje de exceso en anti
américo es igual a 75% menos 25% y esto
es igual a 50% tenemos 50 por ciento de
exceso de s enantiómero así que tenemos
una solución con una pureza óptica del
50%
para el último problema tenemos una
mezcla de colesterol natural y so
enantiómero esta mezcla tiene una
rotación específica de -27 y nuestro
objetivo es calcular el porcentaje en
anti homérico de la mezcla bueno eso lo
podemos hacer usando esta ecuación de
arriba donde el porcentaje de exceso en
anti homérico es igual a la rotación
específica observada entre la rotación
específica del enantiómero pour y para
obtener el resultado en porcentaje
podemos multiplicar por 100 entonces el
porcentaje de exceso en anti homérico es
igual a la rotación específica observada
que es de menos 27 menos 27 entre la
rotación específica del enantiómero puro
que para el colesterol natural vimos que
este menos 30 y 1.5 y esto lo
multiplicamos por 100
usemos la calculadora en este caso no
necesitamos poner los signos negativos
así que solamente dividimos 27 entre 30
y 1.5 y esto lo multiplicamos por 100
esto es igual a 85 puntos 7 que lo
podemos redondear a 86% entonces el
porcentaje de exceso en anti américo es
del 86% listo la siguiente pregunta dice
qué porcentaje de la mezcla es
colesterol natural vuelve el 86 por
ciento corresponde al exceso en anti
américo entonces
si pensamos en que esto es el porcentaje
de colesterol natural colesterol natural
el resto es decir el 14% debe ser la
mezcla race mica y si el 14% corresponde
a la mezcla race mica eso significa que
la mitad es colesterol natural y la otra
mitad es el enantiómero entonces el 7%
el colesterol natural y el 7% es
enantiómero enantiómero entonces cuál es
el porcentaje total del colesterol
natural en la mezcla bueno es igual a 86
más 7 que es igual a 93
la respuesta es 93 % 93% de la mezcla es
colesterol natural esto puede llegar a
ser un poco confuso pero vamos a
verificar que la respuesta sea correcta
nosotros sabemos que la suma del
colesterol natural total y el
enantiómero debe ser igual a 100
entonces el colesterol natural
corresponde al 93%
ante homero es del 7%
obviamente 93 por ciento más siete por
ciento es igual al 100 por ciento y
también sabemos por el problema anterior
que el porcentaje de exceso en anti
américo es igual al porcentaje de uno de
los enantiómero menos el porcentaje del
otro enantiómero entonces podemos decir
que el porcentaje de exceso en anti
américo es igual a 93% menos 7% y esto
es igual al 86% que es lo que obtuvimos
aquí abajo esta es una muy buena forma
de corroborar que resolvimos bien el
problema